[Music]
hey everybody its charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see ant-man in
the wasp there's a whole bunch of stuff
that they reference and never completely
pay off during the movie which is then
laying seeds for big things that will
come later in other big MCU movies so we
got to break all this down if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video obviously spoiler
warning if you have not seen ant-man and
the wasp yet we'll be talking about very
specific details so there are a couple
big villain groups during ant-man and
the wasp that they set up but never
completely pay off just laying seeds is
what Kevin Feige talks about and some of
these you guys probably picked up on
some of them were more obvious than
others so the first big one is that we
find out that ghosts father is called
Elias Starr he worked with Hank Pym back
during his shield days during the 70's
in the 80s along with the Goliath
character you had to imagine that the
end of Hank Pym z' days when he left
shield was that flashback during the
first ant-man movie the Pym particle is
the most revolutionary science ever
developed help us put it to good use as
you trim me into your errand boy and I
try to steal my research if only you'd
protected Janet with such ferocity dr.
Pam
easy time you mentioned my wife again
and I'll show you ferocity don't look at
me you said it Alliance star is ghost
biological father but here's the really
big thing if that name sounds familiar
he is a comic book character
he's called egghead and he's a member of
the Masters of evil so you're like okay
I kind of see where they're going with
this they do a pretty good job of
explaining ghosts backstory how she got
her powers but also in doing that they
lay in a bunch of references
when ghost is confronting hank pym with
the knowledge of her parents death
saying that he fired him tried to
discredit him and he tried to recreate
his experiment that's what led to the
explosion the gave her the powers it was
a little bit of a threat in the movie
where they were trying to make hank pym
seem like this huge [ __ ] but he
wasn't lying when he was talking about
Elias start this is Marvel laying more
Easter eggs for future movies that they
can pay off later hank pym says that
Elias Starr was a traitor and a thief
tried to steal his technology and
discredit him
so he fired him he went off on his own
tried to recreate it and when you see
the quantum tunnel explode and give
ghosts her powers it seems like her
father was trying to recreate that
technology to sell it to the highest
bidder or one of the other big villain
groups because that flashback was
happening 30 years ago the makeup of the
MCU was a little bit different than it
is today so there were a couple big
villain groups that he could have been
working with the de facto big one was
Hydra Hydra was still around thirty
years ago but I think the reason why
they used the Elias star character is so
they could do the Masters of evil Easter
Egg
we have Baron Zemo and present-day
obviously he's not a member of the
Masters of evil he's just a person from
sokovia that turned into a big bill and
it could pop up later in a Thunderbolts
movie anywhere they want to put him so
whatever they do with it the MCU version
of the Masters of evil is gonna have to
be a little bit different but that's par
for the course for the MCU but if you're
not a big comic book reader the Masters
of evil in the comics are made up of
Baron Zemo Justin hammers daughter the
shadow council who's actually a Secret
Avengers villain remember they set up
cap Secret Avengers during Infinity Ward
that's Scarlet Witch
Captain America Black Widow in the
Falcon as far as we know that probably a
couple other people helping them out but
that's the main team then get this
Doctor
octopus also a member of the masters of
evil at a certain point he's a
spider-man villain that we have not seen
in the MCU yet and also Ultron five I'm
not expecting Ultron to come back in the
MCU on planet earth if he ever comes
back in the MCU it's probably gonna be
in a space based movie aa annihilation
conquest through the annihilators I
think that would make more sense
inside note the shadow council that I
just mentioned they worship an extra
dimensional being that's said to be the
source of power of the ultimate
nullifier which is a big Fantastic Four
Easter Egg it's sort of like this
Galactus catch-all weapon that's meant
to be this super big MacGuffin power
source that you can use to destroy the
multiverse
create the multiverse within the context
of the MCU it could potentially be used
as a big mystery box item like the
tesseract back during phase one or the
Infinity Gauntlet in present day just a
device of incredible power that anybody
would want to get their hands on so
remember a lot of these are seeds
the Kevin Feige is laying that could
turn into any number of different things
depending on how the future goes like
some plans are set in stone some things
are just open-ended and I think in
certain cases like this when they're
referencing villain groups it's
open-ended just in case this fox Disney
deal completes by next year and they get
access to those Fantastic Four x-men
characters there's just a lot of things
that these Easter eggs can grow into in
future movies depending on what IP they
have access to separately next big
villain group that they set up during
the movie and then never completely pay
off Sonny Burch when he's talking to
hope at the beginning of the movie says
that he's trying to convince Hank Pym to
sell his technology to what he calls a
very dangerous group of people who don't
take no for an answer
we know they're not Hydra because they
got rid of Hydra way back during Winter
Soldier they're not really a big villain
group anymore it's not like they're
gonna go back to that in a big Marvel
movie the other big villain group that
they also kind of destroyed back during
Iron Man 3 was aim because that was all
Aldrich Killian he created that group
Iron Man defeated him even though they
may be still exist they're really not a
huge threat anymore so what is the big
villain group led by a very big tech
genius that they're slowly setting up
through the spider-man movies outside of
the Masters of evil like that other
Easter Egg it
sounds like Sonny Burch is selling black
market tech to the MCU version of Norman
Osborn who has not been mentioned
anywhere in the MCU remember because
they're just kind of saving him for
later on who will probably later we find
out co-opt the services of the tinkerer
who escaped at the end of spider-man
homecoming so he's still floating around
looking for another evil patron to fund
his experiments then you have to imagine
that Sonny birch would not shut up about
how quantum energy was the future and
that sounds exactly like something that
Norman Osborn and Oscorp
would want to get their hands on so
obviously we know that spider-man movies
are building towards the sinister six
team-up there's just a couple huge
characters that you have to include in
that that we haven't heard anything
about Norman Osborn Doctor Octopus they
could appear anywhere that's why Kevin
Feige says they lay seeds that they can
pay off later some of those references
are very specific and we know exactly
what the referencing like when they talk
about time vortexes it's very clearly
meant to set up time travel at the
beginning of Avengers 4 but things like
this the group that sunny birch is
working for of mysterious villains that
could turn into almost anything it's
just that right now you know like in the
next couple of movies there's this one
big villain group that they're trying to
set up in the spider-man movies and it
makes sense that you would reference
them in a smaller Marvel movie in a very
vague way so that it becomes one of
those moments that hardcore fans really
go crazy about but just a reminder side
note there are other tech based villains
that would want to get their hands on
Pym tech and quantum energy do they just
don't have access to right now at the
moment that they could get access to if
the Fox Disney deal goes through Doctor
Doom is probably the biggest one like on
any given day he could be either an
Ironman villain because of all that
technology that he's involved with he's
a scientist but he also practices magic
so he could be a doctor strange villain
so Doctor Doom is actually a pretty
great villain for almost any really big
Marvel character depending on the way
you use him and whatever the stories
demands are if they were gonna go
full-blown masters of evil I would
rather see them pop up during a black
panther film than a spider-man film just
because spider-man already has so many
characters they haven't done yet and
black panther seems like he's gonna be
one of the other pillars of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe going into phase four
in phase five so you want to save your
biggest Marvel villain groups for your
biggest characters
and then just Black Panther spider-man
hopefully if Captain Marvel pans out and
that goes well you have a lot of space
based villains that you could use for
that let me know in the comments though
who do you think that evil group Sonny
Burch is working for is and when do you
want to see them come back like do you
want them to tie this to spider-man
sinister six Norman Osborn stuff or do
you want them to take it in a different
direction what'll happen is is there'll
be more ant-man videos just because
there's so many other Easter eggs I'll
talk about Kang the Conqueror because
now we're getting into time travel in
the MCU obviously they're setting up
Young Avengers through Cassie Lange's
character I'm gonna grow up to be a hero
just like you dad
so there's just so much stuff to unpack
from ant-man the wasp if you haven't
seen it yet and for some reason you
watch this video be sure to go check it
out because it is a lot of fun click
here for my post credit scene video and
click here to re-watch that spider-man 2
teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]